this is truly the greatest farming
simulator game of all time I sure love
farming Oh new map new possibilities new
life go I swear to god don't mess with
me why does none of them work
you better work not this [ __ ] again I
swear to God
[ __ ] you I'll go in my bumper ok ex fold
wings what motor on the motor is on as
you can clearly so see go go
yes yes yes fly on the wings Bach Oh
what happens okay H giggles my butt oh
yay oh ha ha kills me excuse me FedEx no
one was talking to you no one know I
likes you piece of [ __ ]
god I hate you I'm trying to farm here
[ __ ] my son of a [ __ ] yes it's
doing it I think oh god I'm controlling
it I didn't know I could control it
ah never mind never mind everything I
just said I'm going backwards of course
the [ __ ] is wrong in the hand
I think helicopters are supposed to fly
but I'm not 100% on it [ __ ] am I go
on my PR Joe get some [ __ ] I love my
piaggio a kebab I go Savio hey girl
Oh Mamma Mia say Bella come Eva Bella oh
ah
let's do some sweet tricks god damn it
damn that's feed bro oh it's a biker
dude [ __ ] yo what there we go I got it I
got it I got it I got it I got it I got
it I got it I got I got I got okay Betsy
push the plane [ __ ] oh wow Betsy Betsy
they look at me like that busy Missy
Betsy Betsy calm down back what are your
dress I am I hate Yelp go Bessie flight
make me fly Bessie Bessie Bessie stop
holding me down forward you piece of
[ __ ] this is not forward to to sunset we
will fly okay here we go here we go
we're getting week we're getting speed
we're getting speed we're getting speed
we're ready to take off any minute now
any second now Annie I can't believe it
worked I can't believe it where it works
damn it are you serious yeah Wow finally
figured it out took me about six hours
no big deal let's see how Betsy's doing
Betsy I love you I love you Bessie you
are my friend
that's right Bessie and was beautiful up
there I wish I could take you with me
one day
cows can cows can't fly Bessie how many
times do I gotta tell you hey what do we
got here all right
aah what this [ __ ] is happening what how
did that happen Oh farming disp AF huh
ah ye whoa Jesus
hey [ __ ] you FedEx I'm rich [ __ ] [ __ ]
Oh God help I'm fine I think oh oh I'm
fine nope yeah I'm fine I'm fine I know
I'm a space okay I don't ah there we go
we're fine let's do some jumps here we
go baby
sickest jump ever breath oh my god just
let me ah stupid car you're dumber than
Bessie oh ye Bessie are me hey Bessie
what are you doing here friend Missy
let's wreck those cows
are you serious
the power of Bessie is unmatched
my trusty bicycle I want to ride my
bicycle I want to write god dammit sorry
to ride a bicycle main and this is
school [ __ ] riding cows when you can
ride bikes you later Betty [ __ ] yeah
that was sick this helicopter that I
could never get to work I want to try it
now
still it still doesn't [ __ ] work
right Scout Barney hey who you [ __ ]
wait you think you can [ __ ] with 40 40
[ __ ] yo no matter if you work on mad if
you were okay
matter who you are bori going [ __ ] yo
you don't [ __ ] with party no one [ __ ]
with party
happening baby dami
hey you guys you guys you guys good
you're good ruff what goes here goes
here goes damn it
Oh back flip front flip [ __ ] flip
I don't know what to go out oh god what
am i flying oh god oh god oh god son of
a [ __ ] come on mom what
um skid-man skank
what am i dear
yeah physics that's how it done oh
alright brothers help you enjoy this
video if you did hit that like button
every time you leave a like used you
save a Bessie the beast thanks for
watching and as always stay awesome